happy easter everyone so for the past
several years my sisters and I have had
Easter egg hunt welcome to the easy Arik
Easter egg hunt 2011 this year I've got
a head cam but I can be hands-free but
this year we thought let's make the
stakes even higher
let's have $8,000 egg hunt so we had to
shove some twenties inside of here and
this is what I came up with I'm a little
worried though because it is a little
bit rainy ground as little muddy so
maybe I should put this inside of like a
ziplock bag or something my dad is gonna
hide the golden egg and that our egg
hunt will commence happy Easter 2019
let's go
the egg hunt is about to start free yeah
hello how are you good how are you put
your little yellow ears I've got pink
Janice got blue we've got time-lapses of
plenty we've also got the drone up it's
during a hyperlapse right now to see it
is that you're a Happy Easter
for my camera of choice I'm gonna be
using the insta 361 X here it is ready
wait is it happening now
okay yours are falling off Brianne
cheated okay oh my god
[Music]
where you didn't even bother trying to
find other eggs she went straight for
the source
[Music]
my baby lens just suffered an injury
this is not okay though
good thing this was on there probably
protected it so you have breanne found
the freaking golden egg was in 20
seconds she didn't even try to find any
other eggs she was smart we were not
I guess I'll bring my drone down now
[Music]
oh there is so much Sara Sara like free
em the goal Oneg our winner our ultimate
champion look at that bag like this
looks like something illegal I'm wasting
any time why didn't you guys asked me
what my game plan was I wasn't gonna
tell you in the interview oh my god I'm
a liar go for no egg but this one it
wastes time picking up those other basic
eggs with nothing in them Wow
well it has a lot I can't wait to keep
this I'm gonna put it right in the
savings that's so boring what we've
landscaping this is like an Easter
miracle this has been the best Easter
ever
I have landscaping that needs to be done
that was some fake grass the grass isn't
growing
they say it's nicer grass oh you're done
you give it I have to mix the spot
because I got burned by the flamethrower
well I don't have a single bush or
plenty or expensive yeah I know I didn't
graduation
[Music]